they're playing a waiting game at this
hostel for asylum seekers in berlin
the refugees who've made it here are
sheltered and safe but they don't know
if they'll be allowed to stay in germany
sheikh tajudin from pakistan has been
waiting for 15 months to see if his
request for asylum will be granted
everyone gathers in the kitchen the one
thing they have in common is they've all
left their homelands but for very
different reasons
tajirin comes from karachi where 2500
contract killings are carried out each
year
one took place on his doorstep
and that's why
i have to left the country
unfortunately
and it doesn't look like i can go back
near future
it was an odyssey for these men just to
get to germany
from syria first entered the eu through
bulgaria
bulgaria
was almost as bad as syrian
but it's very different here in germany
especially how they deal with children's
rights
germany currently rejects close to 40
percent of asylum applications and al
mustafa's could be one of them that's
because eu law states that refugees must
seek asylum in the eu country in which
they were first registered
and for him that's bulgaria
serves the tea families are allotted the
biggest rooms in the hostel
imadal mustafa's family was torn apart
when they fled syria he only found his
wife mary two months later
says they're still waiting to be
reunited with two of their children
who've been located in a refugee camp in
turkey
no that is not permission to
get fled your permission they envision
what their future might look like in
germany
but they'll only be allowed to work if
and when they're granted asylum
had his own business in pakistan he
tells us he can't stand sitting around
with nothing to do
i am very useful myself i am good for
the community good for the people and i
have so much to give you back to this
society
and a few days a month he's able to do
just that
then tajudin whips up pakistani dishes
as part of an initiative in which
refugees and germans cook and eat a meal
together
for 35 euros per person
guests get a crash course in pakistani
cuisine from sheikh tajudin
it's almost the same recipe we need
fried onion
you need
yogurt
ninon
is one of the co-founders of the project
we simply noticed that we learned so
little about the people who come to
germany to start a new life
and that these people really don't get
the chance to know us either
so for us cooking is a great way to
bring these two parallel societies
together
refugees and germans
and make them one and
flirt
the initiative from berlin has now
expanded to cologne hamburg and munich
what started as a university project is
now a major enterprise with help from
crowdfunding the organizers are bringing
out a second cookbook
while dinner is cooking in the oven
there's time to chat the guests want to
know more about tajudin
they asked why he had to flee karachi
and there is a reason like you know like
a lot of gangs things like a lot of
politicians nerdy politicians
the main thing in pakistan at this
moment
there's no justice
chicken lentils rice and flatbread folks
are lining up to give it a try
when these
project people nino and bantu they came
to me and i
found this is a good way to get interact
with the community but yes i start the
journey in the heim i'm still in the
heim
evenings like this are a nice way to
pass the time
but tajurin hopes that someday one of
the guests will give him a job as a cook